jean paul belmondo demetriou salaires
détective privé non c'est un monstre
sacré du cinéma français qui nous a
quittés jean paul belmondo c'est une
carrière riche qui s'étale sur cinq
décennies et compte plus de 80 films
la ville après avoir interprété quelques
petits rôles au théâtre et au cinéma sa
rencontre avec jean luc godard chant
xavi et son destin d'acteurs avec les
films à bout de souffle il devient une
figure de proue de la nouvelle vague oui
j'en ai marre sa collaboration avec
godard se poursuivra avec les films une
femme est une femme et pierrot le fou
au cours de sa carrière il a travaillé
avec les plus grands de françois
truffaut je fais un seul métier en
passant par louis malle
jean paul belmondo était également un
passionné de sport un casse cou qui
faisait lui même ses cascades
[Musique]
son personnage driel du fourquet dont
l'homme de rio dans ses scénarios
librement adapté des aventures de tintin
inscrits romaine steven spielberg pour
la création d' indiana jones et des
aventuriers de l'arche perdue qu'il a
réussi à concilier ces deux types de
cinéma compense souvent irréconciliables
cinéma d'auteur cinéma populaire il
excellait dans les deux et donc il avait
son public
des deux des deux côtés l'as des as le
professionnel le magnifique jean paul
belmondo c'est près de 130 millions de
spectateurs en carrière
au québec il tourne en 1985 dans le film
hold up d'alexandre arcady dont l'action
se déroule à montréal le jeune guillaume
lemay thivierge faisait également partie
de la distribution qui avait été
extrêmement gentil doux
joyeux et très rigolo avec tous les
enfants dit à plusieurs enfants sur le
tournage pour moi c'est l'incarnation
d'un à temps complet
également comédien de théâtre il s'était
produit sur les planches au québec
notamment dans frédéric ou le boulevard
du crime d'eric emmanuel schmitt moi
j'ai toujours essayé pas eu assez de
rapprochement cinématographique et
théâtrale entre le québec et nous en
2001 il est victime d'un accident
vasculaire cérébral qui le laisse
grandement diminué ses apparitions
étaient rares mais en 2017 jean paul
belmondo avait reçu un césar hommage
pour souligner sa carrière d'exception
sur les réseaux sociaux des réactions
ont été nombreuses et unanime d'un bout
à l'autre du spectre politique français
tous ont tenu à souligner le décès d'une
trésor national un acteur la gueule et à
la gouaille inimitable une carrière et
un itinéraire d'exception pour cet
enfant gâté du cinéma français ici n'est
by alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal